[Music]
let me tell you what today is it is
September 21st 2018 is the launch of the
new iPhone 10 10 s Mac time here in
Union Square at the Apple Store four
years ago my sister and I were sleeping
outside Santa Monica in a tent waiting
for our iPhone 6 boy go ahead that it
looked like your doghouse we're
beginning the campout so here's the line
of people everybody's lining up so
there's the first let's start the first
person in line isn't even here right now
dude behind my blog hi blog and like the
biggest I just did that and I'm freaking
out
[Music]
hi are you guys first in line I was
about to take your spot cuz they said
first in line just stepped away how are
you he's had my vlog hi so what time did
you get here Wednesday morning what's
today they've been here since Wednesday
watching your videos for forever that's
cool Wednesday Wow
I'm so proud of you guys so the whole
thing about this store is there's this
beautiful front that also opens up but
there is a back we have 15 minutes until
the store open so let me take you guys
for a quick tour the crazy thing is this
store has been open for what do you say
like a year and a half two years Wow oh
my god I feel like it's just open not
too long ago I spent a lot of my time in
San Francisco when I first moved to
California and I was outside for the
first iPad launch I had so many videos
in Apple stores in San Francisco and I'm
starved I don't think I've made a video
on this one yet actually I'm Cisco Apple
store it's just so fun to be back here
at one of my favorite stores this is the
back they've got like this nice little
fountain it's so beautiful and they have
trees inside trees outside
oh I love it okay
there's something that I just love about
being on the news do you think I can get
on the news today guys I love the news
for your first iPhone
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I guess now it's time to go shopping I
gotta get a new case with my phone so
what do you think oh I did you the
lavador does look really good yeah I'm
also gonna need what is this like for
you knowing how much the time and effort
and work you guys have put into this to
see how happy you guys make people you
know I think that's just it the products
made people are happy why they line up
it's why all the excitement I mean it's
honestly it's the day of the year that
we so look forward to design creates it
and it gets all the way here into our
hands but then I would say the
difference is our boys yes I mean it
they make all the difference in the
world great products great employees
like you said that's where people I know
I've met so many people in the Apple
stores that are now like my best friends
like I've come into the Genius Bar
asking questions and now like there's
some like Melissa's friends like you
guys hire some of the greatest people so
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
wait I can't believe we're matching look
at that camera quality mark
[Music]
super HDR buy a super nerd that sounds
even better to be honest next year next
time I'm super so my sister helps me for
the past like four or five days filming
so many videos for the new iPhone and
the new Apple watch so I'm going to get
her present the new Apple watch
we've even heard of the stainless steel
in the space black so let's go do a
little shopping I just bought these
pieces on my phone
thank you so much
did you get your phone yes oh my gosh
I'm so freaking excited thanks to our
video last night I made a decision so
that's amazing oh this is like I just
watched your video yesterday you're
gonna love it somebody meets you and now
I am going to head to the airport and
fly home so thank you Apple
thank you guys for watching if you
enjoyed this video or any of my other
videos make sure you hit subscribe hit
the bell so you're notified when I make
new videos and I'll see you guys in the
next video bye
[Music]